Movies have the power to
connect people by common ground.
I might not know something
about someone else,
and by watching
this movie, I get
to connect with whoever
made this movie and whatever
story that they're telling.
They are something that
you can identify with,
and you can connect with it just
like you can with anyone else.
It's movies that
really have the power
to connect people with ideas
and connect people with others
who are not like them.
Movies are powerful
tools for empathy.
I think it's the
closest thing we
have to be able to see the world
through someone else's eyes.
You can experience other
cultures, other circumstances,
other places.
Places that you've never
been, you may never go.
It's really about reminding
us that we're all one,
and that we all go through
the same pains and joys
and struggles.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
The one thing I love is when
you go to a movie theater
and you feel the
emotion from the screen
sweep over the audience.
The way that that
crowd almost becomes
like one living
being you're a part
of that's absorbing this movie.
That is so important, I
think, for human beings.
Movies have given people
sanity during this really
unprecedented time.
And it gave me a sense of pride
to be a part of something that
helps people come together and
keeps their families feeling
a sense of normalcy.
I really have come to love films
that bring families together.
And I've tried to do that
with most of my films.
I try to make stories that
both children, their parents,
and their parents' parents
can all appreciate.
On different levels, but
all together as a family.
Movies have the power to unite.